>> Tucker: FINAL EXAM.
WE PIT 2 NOTED NEWS EXPERTS
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER TO FIND OUT
WHO IS PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
NEWS.
OUR DEFENDING CHAMP AND HER
CHALLENGER IS FOX CORRESPONDENT
PETER DUCY.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
YOU BOTH KNOW THE RULES.
HAND ON BUZZERS.
I ASK THE QUESTION.
THE FIRST ONE TO BUZZ IN GETS TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I FINISH
ASKING IN ORDER TO ANSWER.
EVERY CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH A
POINT.
YOU GET IT WRONG, YOU LOSE A
BEST OF 5 WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> READY.
>> HOW MUCH MORE TIME COULD I
GET?
>> Tucker: NO MORE TIME.
WE ROLL FORWARD.
QUESTION 1.
DOCTORS SAY THEY ARE WORKING
OVER TIME TO TREAT KITCHEN
INJURIES.
PEOPLE ARE CUTTING THEMSELVES
SLICING A CERTAIN FRUIT.
WHAT IS THE FRUIT?
PETER, WHAT IS THE FRUIT?
>> AVOCADO.
FINAL ANSWER.
>> Tucker: FINAL ANSWER.
[LAUGHING].
LET'S GO TO THE TAPE.
>> I STABBED MYSELF IN THE HAND
WITH A KNIFE.
I WAS TRYING TO OPEN UP AN
AVOCADO.
THERE IS A SYNDROME CALLED
AVOCADO HAND.
WE GET THIS ALL THE TIME.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE CORRECT.
THE JUDGE SAID IT SOUNDS AS IF I
FINISHED ASKING THE QUESTION SO
YOU GET THE POINT.
>> ALL OF THOSE YEARS OF
WATCHING THE "VIEW" --
>> PAID OFF.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU LOST 30 IQ
POINTS.
A DARE DEVIL ANIMAL STOLE
A DARE DEVIL ANIMAL STOL
A DARE DEVIL ANIMAL SCAL
A DARE DEVIL ANIMAL SCALE
A DARE DEVIL ANIMAL SCALE A
A DARE DEVIL ANIMAL SCALE A 2
A DARE DEVIL ANIMAL SCALE A 20
STORY BUILDING AND MADE IT TO
THE ROOF WITHOUT FALLING.
WHICH 4 LEGGED NOCTURNAL NAMMAL
WAS THIS?
>> A RACCOON.
>> Tucker: A RACCOON.
GO TO THE TAPE.
>> A DARING RACCOON SCALING A
BUILDING IN SAINT PAUL,
MINNESOTA.
>> A WILD LIFE DRAMA.
20 STORIES IN THE AIR.
>> OH GOD!
>> Tucker: IT WAS A RACCOON.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPRESSED AND
UNDER-RATED ANIMALS.
YOU ARE DECISIVE.
BAM.
THEY ARE GREAT ANIMALS AND DON'T
GET THE CREDIT THEY DESERVED.
IF YOU ARE SICK OF POLL HOLES
ONE PIZZA CHAIN IS FIXING ROADS
THE GOVERNMENT WON'T FIX TO MAKE
SURE YOUR PIZZA DELIVERY GOES
SHOOTINGLY.
-- SMOOTHLY.
SOME CHAIN IS DOING THIS?
>> DOMINOS.
>> Tucker: ROLE TAPE.
>> FIXING ONE POT HOLE AT A
TIME.
>> Tucker: OKAY, WOW.
3 QUESTIONS AND 3 CORRECT
ANSWERS.
IT'S 2-1 PETER.
QUESTION 4.
THE SUMMIT WE WATCHED BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE LEADER OF NORTH
KOREA.
KIM JONG-UN.
TRAVELED TO SINGAPORE WITH AN
UNUSUAL ITEM.
WAS IT A BED, PORTE POTTY OR A
PET PEACOCK.
>> PORTA-POTTY.
>> Tucker: SAYS KATIE.
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> NORTH KOREA LEADER KIM
JONG-UN BROUGHT HIS OWN TOILET
TO THE SUMMIT WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO PREVENT PEOPLE TO GET
INFORMATION ON HIS HEALTH.
THE INTELLIGENCE AGENT SAID WE
WILL JUST GUESS BAD THEN.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS WEIRD.
SO IMPRESSIVE.
NOW MOVING INTO THE FINAL
QUESTION.
THE DECISIVE QUESTION NUMBER 5.
SUDDEN DEATH OVERTIME.
>> I AM NOT READY.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
I AM NOT READY EITHER OBVIOUSLY.
THE LAST QUESTION:
LAST WEEK, WE TALKED ABOUT iHOP
CHANGING ITS NAME.
IT WILL BE CALL iHOB WITH A B.
WHAT DOES THE B STAND FOR?
>> INTERNATIONAL HOUSE OF
BURGERS.
>> Tucker: BURGERS?
WE WILL FIND OUT IF YOU ARE
RIGHT.
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> THE B STAND FOR.
NOT BEER, BACON OR BREAKFAST.
IT'S BURGERS.
YOU CAN GET PANCAKES WITH YOUR
BURG SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
CHOOSE.
>> Tucker: KATIE, YOU WIN AGAIN.
BEFORE YOU COLLECT YOUR PRIZE.
PETER, YOU BUZZED IN.
DID YOU KNOW THE ANSWER?
>> I DID KNOW THE ANSWER AS
BURGERS.
I WAS VERY, VERY SURPRISED AFTER
ALL OF THE BUILD-UP THAT IT WAS
BUGGERS.
>> Tucker: IT'S SO OUT OF THE
CATEGORY.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
GREAT CAME.
KATIE, YOU ARE GETTING THE
COVETED MUG THAT COMMEMORATES